[Music]
how do we honor our 13 year old
daughter's wishes to not take action
against her molester and also do what we
feel is right over 200 times
someone molests a child
before they're finally caught your 13
year old does not get to drive this you
have to report it
[Music]
what up what up what up this is john
with dr john deloney show
so glad that you're here hey if you want
to be on the show love to have you give
me a call at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 you can leave a message
and kelly and
counterpart here uh jenna is also
helping us put the shows together and
she's being
uh she's incredible man and coming up
with some great shows so uh
1-844-693-3291 leave a message let us
know what's going on and uh jenna or
kelly we'll call you back or you can go
to the internet go to johndaloni.com
ask and hey we're doing something a
little bit different
the number of emails
and handwritten letters and uh
people sliding into the old dms i get
um
about confessions things they've done or
that they are just
so here's what we're thinking about
doing thinking about doing a confession
show
um or making it a regular feature on the
show where somebody calls in and says
hey
this happened and i've never said this
out loud i did this thing and i need to
speak it into the world
um and then we can talk about
potentially what happen what comes next
um obviously if you call and say
that you've
hurt kids or the elderly or you abused
anybody i'm clearly going to call 9-1-1
i'm going to call the local detectives
that i'm going to have to uh put in jail
but other than that i won't say anything
to anybody it'll be confidential um
and i won't be confident you'll be
anonymous that's probably a better way
to say that um it'll be anonymous and um
we will not
just give people a chance to speak out
loud what i'm finding is people are
carrying around this really heavy weight
these bricks we talk about on the show
and a they think they're the only one
and b they think it's the end of time if
they speak it out loud
um some of these confessions also by the
way might not be something that you did
but something that was done to you and i
just need to say it out loud i wanted
you to show up and you didn't um
there's been some really healing moments
in my marriage when one or the other of
us have said something to each other
like hey i've been holding on to this
for sometimes years and i just need to
speak this out loud and so i want to
give people a form to do that so
go to johndaloni.com
ask
and um just put confessions in the in
the top of the little box there and uh
fill it out and we will uh
get you on the air it'll be fun so let's
go uh to
charles in finley ohio what's up charles
hey good morning how are you doing man
thanks for taking thanks for taking my
my question i've been you bet
keeping current and listening to the uh
and catching up on me on the
old podcast you become one of my my
favorite personalities just so you know
hopefully i don't smell your head too
much but uh it's already a humongous
square head so yeah yeah if if if james
kelly ever starts slipping riddling in
your coffee to calm me down i may have
to stop listening i think
they put meth in my coffee to slow me
down
yeah i i come for the help but i stay
for the entertainment you know
well thanks man i'm really grateful that
you uh are in the gang with us man so
what's up dude yeah i
i um
i tell people that you're helping me
learn more about me so i can be a better
mate but you know i don't want to make
it all about me i love it i love it
the kids they're uh they're 16 17 now so
i know it's a little bit late you know
they really get a lot of their um their
their good habits around the age of six
seven eight
but um
summer's coming up and i've been
thinking a lot about the fact that we've
always been a little
sloppy and letting them
sleep in really late want to would till
noon if we let her you know lay around
watch tv
and i'm just kind of i'm wanting to
balance
how healthy
you know if it was up to me i'd wake
them up at six o'clock and say oh come
on let's go find some chickens to feed
we don't have any chickens let's go find
them to feed you know get them at six
o'clock get them working
but i know that's also not
you know really you know so i'm kind of
wondering what the healthy balance is
that uh you know 16 17 to letting them
have a little bit of slack in the
schedule since high school starts so
ungodly early it's just dumb but uh you
know so
what would you what's your thoughts on
that so before i get going and how
active to stay during the day yeah yeah
so you mentioned something that i wanna
i've never heard and that doesn't mean
it doesn't exist i've never heard that
habits are solidified at six seven and
eight
um so what i would tell you is any day
for any of us is the day to say i'm
gonna start doing something new
um there there's some codified learning
with really young kids for language
development and things like that but
when it comes to like six or seven or
eight it's just your kids are watching
what goes on in their house and what
they're allowed to get away with and
then that just kind of becomes their
world until
the world around them changes right so i
think man 16 or 17 is not too late to
start anything uh so good for you guys
for thinking about it
all right
so
i'm gonna give you
my personal thoughts and then i'm going
to give you the actual truth is that
cool
yeah yeah all right personal thoughts i
love the idea of getting kids up at six
and seven and getting their butts out to
work especially in the summer they can
work save money they can get outside and
get a job they can do all that stuff i
love that stuff
um
that's how i was raised that's how i
grew up i remember in the summers i had
three jobs usually i'd get up and work
at a construction site and i'd go work
at burger king and then i'd mow lawns in
the evening like i was always doing
something right and my dad had a just a
natural inborn if i was just laying on
the floor in the summer it would he had
a visceral like get up and do something
you know what i mean so i know exactly
what you're talking about
um here's the reality and this is hard
for me to say out loud this is me um
having to look at the the data and the
science and
say the
my favorite words in the world when
other people say them and my least
favorite words in the world when i say
them and that is i was wrong
so
my
the teenage brain
and this is from matthew walker's stuff
and it's really
as far as i'm concerned it's irrefutable
and so it's less about i don't care and
more about okay can how can i create a
world around this
the teenage brain is genetically
hardwired to begin to go to bed later
and to sleep later
and there's all kinds of hypothesis as
to why that is but it's just reality and
so i'm even starting my my son my my
middle schooler he i mean we used to
have to say you cannot go to bed before
7 30. he just loved running so hard
until he collapsed and even now like
i'll go to bed and have to go back and
be like dude you gotta turn your light
off and he's just like i'm reading and i
said i know it's great i'm glad you're
reading so all to say is that clock
starts to shift this clock isn't
laziness it's wired in and i hate this
and it's reality okay what you touched
on i think what we're doing to our
teenagers is criminal
for how early we make them go to school
and
the lack of sleep on either side of the
learning proposition and the social
proposition is just we wonder why kids
are so fried and cooked and anxious and
exhausted and not making great choices
um it's like just taking your car and
barely putting any gas in it and
flooring it everywhere up until every
stop sign is slamming on the brakes
that's we're doing those poor kids
brains so
what i would love to do is this
teach kids to get enough sleep
and
challenge one of your notions which is
sleeping in or going to bed later and
sleeping in versus
um just laying around watching tv those
are two radically different activities
so here's how i would do it in my house
i would if i was in your in your shoes i
would call a meeting now like a family
meeting go to dinner and say we're gonna
play in the summer and bring your
teenagers along by the way you're
teaching them intentionality and you you
would say this summer you're all going
to get the sleep that your poor sweet
bodies need
and
um
here's what your curfew for the summer
is going to be all like the parent stuff
and then we're going to reverse engineer
it the tv only will come on on saturdays
that's a full stop thing and so i'm
going to take away some of these other
issues like screen time and your phone's
going to be put away you have to have a
job
and um
i it is okay if you sleep in until x y
or z and it's finding that sweet balance
with the crux being you'll have to get
enough sleep and then we're going to
build in the world around it does that
make sense
it does it does and they they both
actually have been putting in some
applications and and one of them has a
uh a part-time drop of summer so they're
definitely not lazy in that regards
but i just want to make sure i help keep
that motivation going
here's the here's where i find the worst
challenge for most most families in this
situation is mom and dad parents
because if you sit down and have this
conversation with them you've got to
participate so if i cut screens out of
my kids lives i got to cut them out of
mine too
and if i say hey we're going to run hard
we're going to work hard but then this
house is going to sleep
um that means i got to go to bed which
is super frustrating and annoying
because i want to be up doing other
things
um and what i'll tell you is if you
struggle with that
it took me about 18 24 months about two
years
to really focus on i'm gonna make sleep
the number one priority and everything
else is gonna come around it and now i
really struggle when i have to like stay
up and work late on a few on a project
because my body's like dude it's 9 30
we're out
and dude it used to be 12 1 2 all the
time
um and so yeah it's funny about
one part-time job may not be enough
get two part-time jobs you know i mean
i'm all about working real real hard um
you can save up a ton of money and get
way ahead yes yes yes yes and get that
sleep um this idea of like here's what i
don't want to project into the world
that you work real hard and starve your
body of food relationships sleep and all
the other resources to keep it going
and then you have these moments of just
crash and do nothing
as though that's restorative because
it's not it continues the degradation
and that
that cycle ends up in college where you
all nighter all nighter all nighter and
then 24 beers and you collapse and you
do the whole thing over again and then
that goes into
the legal profession and the nursing
profession in our jobs where we go go go
go until we collapse and i just want to
back that whole thing up does that make
sense
it does that's something i never even
considered is either working somewhere
full time or a couple part-time jobs
because me i'm trying to think of okay
well if they're not out there working
then i gotta make them get up sweep the
floors dust the house clean the bathroom
go find some chickens to feed and i
don't want to be a slave driver and make
them think that you know it was like
cinderella around here you know and they
have to
you know clean all the how the house
what mom are they doing they're not
doing nothing yeah just earning the
money to keep the house running but
again this is one of those um they're 16
and 17. so here are the the things that
have to get done in the home
before tv ever comes on in the week
the tv only comes on fridays or
saturdays or both right or i don't you
can watch tv whenever you want i mean
i'm not trying to dictate your house but
it doesn't come on until these things
are done and so it's less about you
gotta do this you gotta do this they get
to choose
do we wanna have um
five minutes of running through and
scrubbing the bathroom so that we can
have an hour of watching a show
or do we want to just not have any of
that right they get to choose that and i
think having that conversation and i'd
love to see it like a spectacle
conversation we're going to have that in
our house coming up here's what the
summer is going gonna look like for
everybody guys and my wife's gonna make
a big calendar for and again my kids are
younger but it's it's just a great
exercise so we're gonna do this and do
that
um how are we gonna do this here's what
the schedule is gonna be for everybody
that way we don't just get these me all
of a sudden you look up and half the
summer's gone and all the kids are
sleeping until noon every day or till 10
o'clock or they get up at nine and then
it's just
here's how the house is going to go in
the summertime and um and then you and
your wife can have to really really hold
each other accountable for that
um but hey this is how this is it this
is how family systems change
and yes to all you people out there like
well kids just gotta suck it up and get
out you're right i know i wish that was
the
case but look around
our teenagers are literally falling
apart underneath us
and uh just had a speaker here at the
office
in the safest time in human history and
the most um
expansive economy in human history
and um in a time when our cars are
incredible transportation's incredible
resources are incredible we have the
most spun up anxious and depressed teens
ever
and i for one believe that comes from
anxious and stressed and fried adults
who cannot get off their phones and are
just projecting this anxiety everywhere
and two
we are not letting we're not doing
developmentally appropriate things for
our kids like letting them sleep
like
making them be active like making them
work hard for towards a goal towards a
purpose
and so all of this stuff changes when
families like charles say hey we're
gonna do this summer and the next one
after that and the next after that we're
gonna start doing stuff differently and
that starts with us being intentional
having a good time and mapping out what
this is gonna look like and then we're
gonna hold one another accountable good
for you charles that's awesome we'll be
right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why because
they're committed to doing what's right
for you and that means walking you
through paperwork that's way over your
head that means making sure you get the
right mortgage that you can pay off as
soon as possible and they'll try to
upsell you a bunch of nonsense that's
going to hurt you down the road and most
importantly when you're making this big
life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan two hundred trust me that's triple
eight loan two hundred
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back let's go to
melissa in new canaan connecticut hey
melissa what's going on
hi doctor john how are you i'm good how
are you
i'm great such an honor to speak with
you today dr john very big fan i promise
you the honor is
is mine i i assure you
what's up i'm so grateful that you
called what's up
so dr john i'm
i'm calling uh just having kind of a
two-layered issue i hope that you can
help me with so basically i'm a native
buffalonian buffalo new york um i was
home visiting my parents this past week
when the mass shooting at tops occurred
um that occurred in the neighborhood
where i went to school
i knew people that grew up there and i
second hand no one is a victim
so all this
you know like so many others it's been
very difficult for me to process to
think about much else since it occurred
and i'm kind of taken aback and how much
it's affected me
i'm
the more complicated layer to this is
that i'm actually a counseling student
i'm doing clinical mental health
counseling yes yeah and i'm about to
start my practicum
i'm i want to specialize in trauma
counseling but i'm struggling with
what's happened in buffalo yeah
i'm at a loss i don't even know what i
would say if a client needed to speak to
me about this because truthfully i'm
scared too i'm afraid for my parents to
just be living there now to go to the
supermarket just kind of live their
lives and you know do normal routine
things that we have to do out and about
so you know i the whole thing with this
is i wish i could speak to someone about
this um because i do feel like i'm
struggling but i'm hesitant to say
anything to people especially those that
are in my cohort or my professors
because i wouldn't want them to think
that i'm now unfit for their constant
profession oh man so i'm calling i'm dr
john c if you have any advice on how i
can process this
and also not lose faith in my own
abilities as a counselor i think i've
always prided myself on being a pretty
level
headed and calm person but honestly this
has really rattled my sense of security
there's a lot here
um
so the first i think it's important just
to pause for a second okay and
what happened in buffalo was evil and it
was
senseless doesn't even it's so out of
mind it's in
the insanity right
um
and
being from there this is different than
a news headline this becomes home right
yeah
and knowing people this becomes
like this becomes in your chest this
isn't just in your head anymore right
and so
i think it's important to just stop for
a second honor the folks who've passed
um yeah um honor the folks who showed up
there and got in the middle of all that
mess
so i'm gonna tell you a story i was
working
crisis work um so i would be i was a
dean of students um by day and then at
night um
i was
working with the local police department
and what you're doing is doing death
notifications and all that kind of stuff
right you've probably heard me talk
about that
yeah um so my daughter was two
and um for everybody listening this is a
very very hard story to hear and so i
know that um and i'm i'm being
intentional i'm not trying to be
gratuitous here yeah um
my daughter was two and i and i my son
was about i guess he was eight at the
time and like you i prided myself on how
tough i was and not even that i was that
tough but i could just walk into any
situation and see the craziest stuff
and um i got a call and it
it was just a text message on my phone
that said hey this is what we appears to
happen 10 16. looks like somebody's
passed away
and we need to show up to the hospital
and so i just knew when i showed up to
hospital that usually means that my job
was going to be sitting with
parents um or loved ones
and i showed up to the hospital and
somebody caught me in the hallway and
they said hey here's what's happened
there was a daycare
and it was in an um
about 45 minutes away in a rural area
and they had 15 kids but they were
driving around um toddlers um and they
were driving around
and there was two young people that were
working at this place and they took the
van and they parked it
and they got all the kids out
but they left the two in the back seat
they forgot them
and they stayed in that texas heat
and i um one of them had passed away
already and when i got there was one
more on life support
yeah and mom was 20. my mom was 19 and
dad was 20.
and i walked in
and
here's all i saw
i saw a crowd of people around this
little girl
all i saw was her arm
and
yeah it was from her elbow to her
fingers and i'll remember that picture
in my head as long as i live
and
i had to leave
yeah because that looked like my baby
girl's arm
yeah i had to get out okay
and i felt a lot of shame about that i
felt embarrassed about that my partner
janiece she's one of the greatest women
i've ever known she's incredible and i
looked and said i gotta go and she said
you cannot leave me here that's that's
101 right and i said i cannot be here
and that happened one other time i think
i've talked about on show but all it to
say is i had to leave and it was a
visceral body reaction and here's why
i'm telling you that story
i did trauma for a living still do
yeah
but that one was home
yeah
and there's it's important for you as a
growing therapist as a new counselor to
understand that our job is to wade into
other people's messes
and there are seasons when other people
need to wait into hours
yeah so the greatest gift you can give
your professor and your cohort is to say
this has broken me for a season
yeah i'm hurting
and what that's
it's it's it's not only not gonna hurt
your professional character and fitness
to be a therapist it's gonna humanize
you and give you a different layer when
somebody comes in and says i'm scared
you're gonna be able to go yeah i know
you see what i'm saying
yeah i do and so
this is a great gift what i would tell
you as a therapist you have to have
people that you can talk to
yeah did you grow up in a situation
where you needed to just be stoic about
stuff
absolutely
i definitely did you know
my my parents are are immigrants and you
know where they're from
you just don't talk about that kind of
stuff i you know i myself have
been uh on the other side of the chair
and i've been you know in therapy and i
know how healing it can be and that's
why i wanted to become a therapist
myself but
i sort of feel like when i entered the
profession
maybe dr john you could tell how much of
a rookie i am i almost felt like
now i can't be you know that client so
to speak i kind of have to
be strong and and and know it all to be
able to survive in this profession quite
frankly is
you know i'm not able to to fall apart
at everything and
um you know we're here to help people
through the worst moments of their lives
and for me it's just
it hurts like you were saying i think
it's kind of that both and situation um
it's just
i try and talk to my husband about it
you know but he's not from buffalo i
think really only people from there
might truly be able to understand how
completely painful this is for our city
and how disgusting it is on so many
levels
um but i i do
wish that i kind of had
an outlet of someone to speak to because
i don't i also don't want to dump on my
husband and you know have him play
therapists to me
that's right
it's been difficult
you are conflating life with your
profession
here and i want you to untangle that
you're hurting
and this is going to require collective
morning for the city this is going to
require collective grief for our country
this is going to require a lot of grief
for you
yeah and that doesn't make you not a
great professional this will be
something that you'll make meaning of on
the back end you already want to go be
about trauma and now you have a
a
you your body is telling you what your
clients are going to be telling you for
years
the idea i've worked with police
officers and swat officers and nurses
and doctors and surgeons everyone in
between
counselors of course i teach graduate
counseling courses
what i'll tell you is
those that bottle this stuff up and
think that professionalism looks like
quote unquote it won't get to me
they end up in ash
yeah so much so that my my professors
said if you are a counselor and you do
not have somebody to go talk to
we're going to consider that unethical
it is a
how in the world can i show up
fully for you when i'm not full but i'm
not home
right yeah
and so i've got to go sit with somebody
and i'll tell you this one of the
greatest moments of one of the greatest
breakthrough moments of my life was
sitting with a counselor who i saw him
get tears in his eyes as i was talking
really wow and i remember now i've heard
of stories of counselors weeping through
sessions and the clients are like dude
i'm coming to you man
so it didn't it didn't that tear didn't
say he's weak that tears showed me he's
with me
yeah and that's a totally different
proposition
often when you grow up in a home where
showing feelings got you hurt or not
even got you hurt we just don't do that
yeah then you're faced with something
then you have a choice and it's really a
crossroads here as a human not as a
counselor as a person
am i going to be somebody that continues
this family generational trauma of
bottling stuff up and sucking it up
or am i going to
learn how to be heard and to say i'm sad
and to say i'm heartbroken and to weep
bitterly
yeah and to not sleep for days on end
and have people in your life that you're
being open with
i'm going to teach my kids something
different i'm going to teach my clients
something different i'm going to change
how this thing works do you see what i'm
saying
i do so here's what i want you to do
yeah you may not have done this here's
the here's the protocol that i would be
using if i'm in your exact shoes okay
yeah um
can i ask you another personal question
of course are you african-american
no but i am a person of color okay i'm
i'm mixed i'm yeah but uh so this is
intensely personal yeah yes
yes it is because this person came for
you
that's your body reacting okay do not
run from this what happened is
terrifying and scary and if you'd been
there you would have been on the list is
that is that fair
okay oh absolutely that's one of the
first things that i thought that this is
someone that
would hate me
not hating nobody's knowing me
not alive they want you dead yes yes
yeah that's a that's a different level
right yeah yeah um i hate the atlanta
braves i don't want any of them dead
right this is another level
and so
running from that reality is going your
body will continue to try to solve for
that reality while your mind is trying
to distract itself with other things
yeah and you'll find a golf so here's
what i want you to do
number one you have to be around other
people
and you have to tell your story full
stop okay that can be one person that
can be a professional that can be five
people that can be on a group phone call
i would rather be in person but i know
you don't live in buffalo right so this
is home
um i'm thinking of when i wasn't in
houston where i'm at home and all my
friends and community and family and
hurricane harvey hit
and i felt
this panic i was watching my friends
send videos of their houses falling down
and we were on the phone we were talking
i did the best i could and it was still
unnerving and i just let myself be sad
for a while do you see what i'm saying
and so i want you to
get on the phone and say i'm not doing
okay
here okay i want you to get a meeting
with your
counseling supervisor
okay and say this happened
and this is my home
and i even have a
a
one-step relationship away from one of
the victims and i'm really hurting
tell somebody
in it tell somebody um
that's got some important mentor role in
your life that okay yeah honor your body
that way okay and listen if that person
if you're a supervisor if she or he says
well i don't know man you're gonna have
to suck it up
dude
they are cashing out they i mean they're
they're a terrible terrible mentor
they're not gonna say that though yeah
they're gonna probably reach across and
say can i hug you and hopefully you'll
say yes if you feel safe
um
here's number two
yeah i want you to go to walmart amazon
um
barnes and noble whatever and get a
small journal and start writing this
stuff down
okay i want you to write down how pissed
off you are and raged out and angry you
are
yeah i want you to use the shooter's
name
i want you to write down how angry and
sad you are and use the victims names
and talk about your friends and your
mom's still there and your dad's still
there i want you to be really specific
but i want you to write this stuff down
okay yeah and and
when you have a good day i want you to
write that down too
this isn't all about negativity and
awfulness okay
that's true
here's the last thing
here statistically speaking
this is not going to happen again there
in buffalo
i really hope so i'm so afraid that it's
called you i know i know but so here's
what i'm trying to say statistically
speaking is probably going to happen
but it might
okay and moving forward in our life
we got to hold that tension
and so
the chance you have to go back and visit
your home
it's important
yeah and we've um i've met with students
who are immigrants and international
students and when there's a great
tragedy they've they taught me this
that's why i ended up going back home
after harvey i had to go be there
yeah and i don't i can't explain it i
don't i don't know any studies i had to
go put my feet on the ground and look
around and say okay the sun is still
shining here yeah and people are still
driving their cars and people are still
laughing and the astros are still losing
like i have to get i got to get there
you know what i mean
so
at some point as hard as that's gonna be
i want you to go home
and i want you to hug people real real
tight
and i want you to if you can go visit
the grocery store
here with not alone with okay
and that's a part of your healing
journey to put your feet back on the
ground in that place where home is okay
so
in another in a similar but different
scenario
yes i left that hospital that night
and i went home
and you don't dare wake up a sleeping
two-year-old because
you know i mean that i'm gonna end up in
uh in a morgue with from my wife
but i went home
and i went and woke my eight-year-old up
here and he's half asleep and i hugged
him as hard as i could
that was me going home okay yeah
yeah and i had to put my hands on him
and feel him and say okay
that's me regulating my body okay
so the three counterpoints here are
connection
writing the stuff down be honest about
your thoughts and feelings
it's the central idea of going home
because this is you this isn't about
trauma this is about your home and
here's the fourth one make sure you're
taking care of your body move your body
you got to eat you got to laugh you
still got to be intimate with your
husband if you feel up to it like you
got to do life stuff okay yeah yeah
but do have a season of morning so i
tell you all that stuff i just threw a
lot at you tell me how that feels as i'm
telling you that are you like oh my god
you're an idiot youtuber or
is this ringing true
no it absolutely rings true and um
you know
you know dr john one of the things that
i've shared in my classes i've also
acted as a ta is is what you've taught
as
periods of life are seasons
you know i i realize that this is like a
season that that i'm going to be sad but
you know i think
the other part of me just feels like i
always need to be strong and it's just
it's difficult
it's difficult let that in today
yeah okay yeah because one day you're
gonna have a little one
and
something bad is gonna happen and you're
gonna immediately go back to that great
stoic we just gotta suck it up that your
parents taught you
yeah
and you're going to look at that little
little
kid of yours and you're going to have a
choice
and you can say
the way we deal with pain
is to build up a wall
or
the way we deal with pain is to be sad
yeah and so honey
you get to come see mommy be sad come
hug me because mommy's really sad
because her friend passed away or
grandmother is sick or one of your
friends you see what i'm saying
i want to give the gift too and then
here's where the strength comes in is on
the making meaning side the now what
okay so i'm not advocating that we all
just go and not do anything
there's a season of grief
and for many of us we got to keep going
to work because we got bills to pay
right yep there's a season of grief
there's a season of grinding it out
and then as the great david kessler says
there's a season of making meaning so
who am i going to be because of what
i've experienced and what i've been
through and that's not for today okay
that's not for today what you'll do is
you'll go back and look at your journal
uh after time and you'll start to go oh
i just keep circling up because you're
going to start writing things and you're
going to circle it you're going to think
about it and suddenly you're going to be
like that's who i'm going to be
yes yes and if i might just add one
thing i think part of what
has made this process difficult for me
is how profoundly angry i feel and um
i think that i'm someone like it takes a
lot for you to rattle me in general but
for me to feel something like rage is
very rare
i felt it maybe only a couple of times
in my life not that there's not things
in the world that you know we're angry
at of course but i mean on a personal
level
um
i feel rage and it's maybe not a an
emotion that i'm not familiar with you
know and so
so i anger is um
anger simply points your body towards
things you care about
yes
rage is when that anger
becomes trapped
yeah and it becomes um explosive
right
and so i want to feel my anger anger is
good it's powerful and it's strong
and then i want to do things that are
going to
honor me and honor my loved ones and
honor my community and honor
what happens next right yeah
and so that means i'm going to write
that stuff down i'm going to go for
walks i'm gonna take care of my body i'm
going to
be open and tell my story and listen to
other people tell their stories i'm
going to hug i'm going to weep
and then i might take another class on
trauma
or i may take another class on racist
idiots who shoot people right i mean
whatever i'm gonna i'm gonna get to the
bottom of it right but that's not right
now right now it's just a season to be
sad
yeah okay
i i need you to hear me say this
you're gonna make a
incredible therapist someday oh thank
you dr john okay
you are thank you and um
the more vulnerable and more open you
can learn to become in your private life
the better therapist you're going to
become down the road
yeah okay
you're so right
cool are we the same team
yes sir we are thank you so much dr john
all right i am so grateful to have
gotten a moment to talk to you and
before we leave
um
you've noticed on this show
whenever somebody calls and says
somebody passed away the first question
i was asking is what was their name
and we have a
challenge in our in our culture we don't
like to say names we like to roll things
off or just use flowery language like
deceased whatever
instead of dead instead of hurt instead
of anger and rage
and so
as always i think it's critically
important
to say people's names
say their name
[Music]
pearl
and ruth
and andre
and roberta
and margus
and aaron
and geraldine
celestine hayward
catherine
we gotta do better guys
we're gonna miss y'all
we're gonna do better
we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else
but when it comes to making time for
vacation for exercise for talking with a
mentor for sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
betterhelp is online therapy that offers
video phone even live chat sessions with
your therapist you don't even have to
see anyone on a camera if you don't want
to it's more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours today dr
john dolone show listeners get 10
off their first month so decide to
invest in yourself
you are worth it and go to
betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back let's go to uh
idaho falls idaho and talk to andy
what's up andy
uh
not awesome not awesome oh boy
well i'm hey i'm
i'm grateful that you
called i really mean that so what's up
okay
well my question is how do we honor our
13 year old daughter's wishes to not
take action against her molester and
also do what we feel is right um
oh
boy
justice and i would say a
really important follow-up to that is
that my husband's anger is so
tremendous that um
i kind of fear
um
him taking action against this person on
his own
like he's fantasizing about
hurting this person and
i'm just stuck between a rook and a hard
place because my
i want to take care of my daughter but
i'm also
want to take care of my husband and
how are those how are those mutually
exclusive
[Applause]
well as far as like
she knows that she knew that when she
shared this with her counselor that
it would be reported and at the time
there wasn't a name
and so
i think she was controlling that but
in the details of of what she did share
we figured out who it was
and having that information were now
like
when uh the officer called us
there they said do you know who this
person is and the reality is
yeah we do we're like we're not gonna
lie to the officer right that's wrong
but also we've promised our daughter we
wouldn't
we would honor her wishes and not do
anything so i feel like
yeah okay so
like
i'm gonna give it to you straight as an
arrow okay
um
i
i think i was i was talking to um
a buddy of mine who's a professor in a
med school teaches counseling classes
and her specialty is
um
is this
and i think it's 280
over 200 times
someone molests a child
before they're finally caught
200 plus times
and so i'm gonna give you the
humanitarian answer is your 13 year old
does not get to drive this you have to
report it full stop i'm gonna give you
the federal law standard you have to
report it not reporting it as a crime
you're an adult
okay
um and you don't have to oh no you do
have to press charges and move forward
you gotta get this this this ins this
devastating predator off the street
and right now it feels like the end of
time for your 13 year old
and what she needs is the stability that
says we love you we're gonna walk
alongside you
and this is the right thing right now
and so now you're playing a long game
you're playing a long game of healing
you're playing a long game of love and
connection you're playing a long game of
here's how to handle
anger and frustration and rage
and you're playing a long game for her
relationship with you because you're
going to look up she's going to be 26
and the question is going to be
because there's going to be a trail of
kids in this guy's wake
and
uh
the question will come back how could
you not have done anything
so this is a full stop conversation's
over we're going after a full tilt on
this deal
now when it comes to your husband you've
actually put me in an awkward position
now
because what like an ethical if i know
somebody's considering hurting somebody
else right
that i have to make that call
and so what i would tell you is
your husband i simply don't buy
i don't because i've been raged out of
my mind and i still have a choice
and now it's to a point where it becomes
premeditated so what he's going to
choose to do if he chooses to do
something stupid like go beat this guy
up or go shoot this guy or whatever
if he does something
he is intentionally choosing
to make his daughter's life
in more ash than it already is
because he's choosing to
you know what she's already lost her
autonomy and she's already lost um she's
already been heavily traumatized i'm
gonna take her dad away too
and there's a foolish childish choice
right
uh
that um
you know he's made a promise to me
that he won't do anything but he's just
he's
he just he's black i got it hey a total
dude i got a little girl i totally get
it
yeah
and there's a choice
yeah absolutely you know what i mean i'm
happy to talk to him too have him call a
show um
but yes there's
don't
don't take her dad away too
sure
don't okay so the greatest gift you can
give her right now is to believe her
and here's here's where this is messy
okay here's where this is messy
i've been through a lot of
sexual assault investigations and what i
know is
taking away a victim's autonomy meaning
somebody came in and violated their them
their body their their
values they they took from them
they
they took power and control and a piece
of them
and then they come report that and then
i will go as the as the
as the administrator i go all right well
here's how i'm going to handle this and
they say no no no i go nope this is how
i'm doing it this is the right thing
i can be re-traumatizing
because now you're losing control yet
again of how this thing ends up
and what i would tell you is there's a
difference between working with adult
victims and children
and so we wouldn't let our children
drive a car we wouldn't let our children
aren't there emotionally they're not
there they're not gonna make
great decisions there and so what we're
gonna do the most loving caring thing
you're gonna do is you're gonna say i'm
gonna get this person off the street
and i'm gonna um seek justice for you in
the right way
in an appropriate way in a legal way
and we're going to love and honor you
all the way through
okay i fear we've handled this poorly
from the get-go because
she started freaking out because i know
it took a lot of courage to share this
like
we have five daughters this is like our
worst nightmare we don't do sleepovers
we
you know and so my husband feels i
failed at the one thing right i promise
it would never happen to my my sweet
girls but
i know it took a lot of courage for her
to share it and
and then immediately she wants to like
okay but i don't want to do anything i
just wanna and and she you know was was
like freaking out and unsettled and all
that stuff and so
you know we promised her that we would
not do anything and so like two parallel
realities are happening we're on the
narrative with her is it's fine
we're doing what you asked giving you
power is what we're feeling and then
um the other reality is that we have
been talking with officers and we have
gotten the name there is something filed
and moving forward but then where it
would have to intersect and
make
liars out of us or whatever
with our daughter is is as if there is
like a forensic interview and the way
that that sounds sounds so traumatizing
i mean he doesn't want to do any of it
yeah
so
um
if i'm you in this situation
so let me let me let me back up a little
bit
your husband didn't fail
and you didn't fail
and your daughter didn't fail
you got preyed on
okay
then
um the first rattle out of the bag was
scary and disaster and we say things
like i won't say anything will you just
tell me what's going on i promise i
won't tell i need to know what's wrong
with you are you okay
and they tell you something that you
legally morally have to tell
and now you found yourself in a pickle
right
the single so i'm i'm what i'm telling
you is i'm giving you a pass on that
first i get that
something's not right tell me right and
now you found yourself in a mess
the single worst thing that can happen
moving forward is your daughter loses
trust in you
because then she's completely unanchored
she's already lost trust in humanity she
doesn't have those words yet but she has
um
she's lost control she's lost innocence
all those things
but she's got y'all
and so if i'm you i'm calling a family
meeting asap
um with her and you and your husband and
maybe one or two other people that she
trusts not her own age but maybe another
um mentor a mentor or two that's a woman
or somebody that she trusts maybe from
church maybe from school whatever
maybe you do this in the school um
counselor's office whoever she feels
comfortable with
and we're gonna say hey um
law we have to go forward and say
something
and so this isn't a matter of
um us uh not doing it it's a matter of
we're doing this and we're gonna honor
you at the same time and expect an
explosion and expect and i hate you and
you promised and you're lying to me and
whatever
and the only response that's gonna make
any sense is i love you and i love you
and i love you
okay
the longer this gap goes the more
explosive it's going to be the day the
police show up at school and she's got
to go to a forensic interview is saying
a sane interview and those are not
pleasant at all
well it's probably way too late for a
sane interview but like for a uh and
that's that's that's when you go to the
hospital and have an exam um but
uh for a forensic interview man yeah
those are really really tough real tough
and they're describing it like it's it's
really non-invasive and they can get a
lot of information from you know like
indirect questions and things like that
hey they're gifted
no i mean they're not gonna lie to you
um
but
it's just tough it's tough yeah and if
you're there it's tough to hear those um
your daughter asks those questions it's
a tough task anybody asks those
questions to think about that right
um
my guess is this can i ask you a hard
hard hard question it's totally
unrelated
sure um
if i'm only gonna ask you i'm just gonna
pop i'm just gonna pause it i'm gonna
put under the world
if you have a house
where you get really mad
or you get really quiet
or dad gets really mad at things
those five girls have learned
how to
not quote unquote make mom mad
or make dad angry
if you do that dad's gonna get so mad or
if you say that mom's gonna do put that
away mom's gonna
right and
ultimately that distills down to one
important thing they feel responsible
for the emotional regulation of the
adults in their life and they cannot
carry that
so you
you run that down all the way she's
going to sit in that exam exam i mean
i'm sorry it's not a sane exam she's in
in that forensic interview
and
you're going to be talking or she's
going to be talking and she's going to
look over and see you clenched up i see
you weeping and she's gonna realize oh
my job is to make sure mom's okay
and that's not her job that's your job
is that fair but yeah it came out in
counseling so she's been she's had
crippling inside the depression for a
couple years obviously this is really
insightful with this coming out
and part of you know the counselor did
say that you know she was fearful of
dad's reaction um
and it sounds like she should be
and his default emotion
he's got to stop
he has to stop
so when you say that you know
we can't lose trust with our daughter
that's exactly what are you saying that
it's not necessarily in this i'm sorry
we said we promise but we just can't
this is we have to do this
and
versus like the the long game like you
said like not showing up for her and
saying sorry just no no you you have to
let her know that you're moving forward
with this
she cannot find that out from a police
officer or a courtroom
she has to hear that from you guys
and it can i would open it be very
direct i told you that i would never
tell anybody
and
a
legally i made a statement that i was
wrong i'm not allowed to do this against
the law
and number two
i can't fathom another mom and dad who
loves their daughter as much as we love
you
experiencing this
and so as your mom and i wouldn't pawn
it all off on the legal stuff i would
say as your mom as your dad
this person has to go to jail
and so we told you we weren't going to
tell
we've had to change our mind
and i know this hurts you and i know
this makes you feel out of control but
we're doing what's right
that's how i would i would have that
conversation and then i would stop
i would i wouldn't just keep babbling i
would just say this is the reality that
we're facing now facts are our friends i
said this and i was wrong this is what's
happening now
and what she's going to feel is a out of
control and b
because somebody else is driving now
finally
and dad's got to get his freaking rage
under control because she's going to
drive those emotions further and further
and further into a black hole
because she's scared of what he's going
to do
and he's got to stop acting like a
toddler and act like a grown man and
dude i have a daughter i'm getting raged
out thinking about this okay
it's not a matter of not being angry and
not a matter of not being raged out
i'm saying you cannot grow young
children in a house where they feel like
there's a tiger that can go off at any
moment
and expect them to have any sort of
downstream emotional regulation in their
own life they're going to marry guys
like that
yeah i mean to be fair obviously like
he's not reached out like in the house
like these are moments with me where
he's safe and he can tell me how he's
feeling and stuff like that has been
very tender yeah
no no i i get that i'm not talking about
this one issue i'm saying overall but
you just told me that
no they they're worried about making
dead mad
you know what i mean
so um
and
i know y'all probably told her this but
please reiterate this over and over and
over again very common
that when the police get involved or the
counseling gets involved and mom and dad
get involved and there's all these
things a 13 year old can feel like
they've done something wrong
because those people usually only get
involved when somebody's in trouble
and it's important to reiterate over and
over and over again
i don't care if she
sent text messages i don't care if she
got in a somebody else's car and drove
to this person's house i don't care how
this thing happened what happened is not
her fault
full stop period
adults are supposed to be adult
and she needs to constantly be reminded
constantly be reminded that you love her
that you love her that you love her this
is not her fault
so i'll leave you with this
on a very different situation but a what
i think is a
applicable
um
response
um there's some stuff that went on at
school
and my daughter got in trouble
she's six right so it's not like crazy
stuff
there's enough that my wife called me
during the day which is super super rare
um so i got home i thought about it all
the way home all the way home all the
way home i thought about it i thought
about it i thought about it
and i got home
and she came and meet me at the door
like she always does um and i said hey i
need you to come in my room and her body
immediately dropped
her shoulders dropped
and she knew oh i'm in trouble
and she came in my room and i shut the
door and i sat down on my bed and she
stood in front of me so we were eye
level i said did we have a hard day at
school today
and she looked at the floor and said
yeah daddy i did
and i put her face in my hands
i said i need you to hear me say this
every day i thank god that
he let me be your daddy
every day i thank god that of all the
daughters in the world i could have got
i got you
and i love you
and i gave her a hug
and she's been alive for six years
and the hug i got back
is the single greatest hug i think i've
ever received in my life
and then i let go and she didn't so i
started i re-embraced and we just sat
there
and we sat there and we sat there
there's a time for accountability
there's a time for frustration it's time
for peace and there's a time for all the
things
but there's
never not a time for our kids not to
know i'm in your corner and i love you
and this little 13 year old girl needs
to know mom and dad are in control they
said some things out of the gate they
got to walk that back that's life things
happen and things change but when things
happen and things change we're going to
look at tonight and we're going to tell
you the truth and then we're going to be
about protecting you and our community
we're going to do hard things and this
is not your fault and we
thank god every day
that we get to be your mommy and daddy
i know this is tough tough season andy
and i'm so so sorry please please you
and your husband find somebody that you
can talk to about this please go get a
professional asap
we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things i
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if i do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as i'd love to i can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
i wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what i would say if you
and i were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book i will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the new roads of a well life
moving forward go to johndeloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at johndeloney.com
it was a heavy show today good folks
thank you all for sticking with us and
for riding all the way to the end here
um
it's one of those shows that
i don't know the whole song at the end
thing doesn't always feel right um
and one time i didn't do it and somebody
wrote me a nice note they just said hey
man the song lyrics at the end of the
show helped me
exhale and process what happened and go
so i'm not gonna i'm not gonna not do
them um kelly brought these in and i
think they're phenomenal
it's the great bill withers
and he writes
songs called lean on me and it goes like
this
sometimes in our lives
we all have pain we all have sorrow
but if we're wise we'll know there's
always tomorrow
lean on me when you're not strong
i'll be your friend and i'll help you
carry on for it won't be long until i'm
gonna need somebody to lean on
please swallow your pride if i have
things you need to borrow for no one can
fill those of your needs
[Music]
that you won't let show
you can just call on me brother we need
a hand we all need somebody to lean on i
just might have a problem that you'll
understand
we all need somebody to lean on that's
the purpose of this show we all need
somebody
we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode we just
had a fire like three weeks ago um i
have a 15 month old and a five month old
and i also work so how do i deal with
life
your whole life is on fire what's your
favorite band i don't have one i listen
to a lot of music
so i don't have a favorite so you're a
serial killer that's good you know of
all the people that have hurt me
the most it's kind of been been her how
has she hurt you casey well she's
tried leaving twice
puts the kids
you know
over over me ever since the you know
first kid was born it sounds like she
has no interest in
helping meet your needs